[Musique]
mauvais pour une émission qui touche sur
une actualité encore très brûlante elle
a fait les journaux et la télévision
toute la semaine on en a parlé on va
encore en reparler avec mes trois
invités aujourd'hui il y en a 3 je vous
les présente tout de suite
cindy world bonjour cindy bonjour cindy
vous êtes anishnabe et attikameks un
beau mélange vous êtes toujours
doctorante et chargé de cours à
l'université du québec en abitibi
abitibi-témiscamingue oui et vous êtes
une nouvelle chroniqueuse à espace
autochtone oui on va en parler dans un
instant bonjour isabelle picard dont
jours alors isabelle vous êtes connu à
radio canada parce que vous êtes souvent
invité à plusieurs émissions
parfois oui exactement vous êtes huronne
wendat
n'est ce pas et puis évidemment tout le
monde le sait vous êtes ethnologue et
chargés de cours toujours à lucas oui
c'est un fait et vous aussi vous êtes
une nouvelle chroniqueuse à espace
autochtone on va en parler dans un
instant aussi bon jour et puis viviane
michel la présidente de femmes
autochtones du québec vous êtes innu né
de deux cultures aussi c'est vrai les
québécoises mon père est quelqu'un qui
nous d'accord alors merci d'être venus
aujourd'hui pour répondre à une question
qui est incontournable parce qu'elle a
fait donc les manchettes toute la
semaine et c'est cette ce fameux renvoie
en fait de deux députés autochtone du
parti libéral du canada et on s'est posé
une question et on l'a posée à nos à nos
internautes également et on aimerait que
vous y répondiez et surtout que vous
envoyez vos questions à nos invités
aujourd'hui
alors la question c'est le gouvernement
libéral de justin trudeau va-t-il à
l'encontre des promesses qu'il a faites
aux autochtones en expulsant de son
caucus donc jody wilson wood et john
philpot alors vous pouvez répondre à
cette question et on en voyait d'autres
à nos invités parlons de nouvelles
chroniqueuses présentons l'est cindy on
vous a donc demandé d'écrire une
chronique pas nécessairement chaque
semaine mais selon les évènements selon
les événements plus politiques relatifs
à la poigne ouais mais en fait
ça peut être assez large toujours d'une
perspective autochtone évidemment donc
oui et ce qui est intéressant c'est
qu'on vous avait demandé de votre de
prendre votre temps d'être prête quand
vous vouliez écrire la première
chronique et avec ce qui s'est passé
mardi donc avec l'expulsion des deux
députés autochtone vous avez décidé de
réagir immédiatement pour ou en fait les
gens qui me suivent un peu sur twitter
savais déjà que j'étais très intéressé
au dos aussi depuis comme plusieurs
canadiens depuis plusieurs semaines je
suivais le sort de madame joly webos en
web oui
puis c'est sur le fait qu'il est inquiet
je suis sortie de radio canada puis
finalement on s'est entendu sur le poste
de crime cause de tout ça se passait je
n'ai de voir qu avait été expulsé du
caucus et en plus ça n'avait plus droit
de se présenter pour le parti et va donc
en allant à une soirée des femmes ça
déboule et je savais que ça ferait un
sujet de conversation intéressant voilà
alors votre chronique maintenant elle
est cette première chronique là sur la
page d' espace autochtone donc on va
inviter tous les internautes à aller là
lire si ce n'est pas déjà fait
isabelle picard nous vous avons invités
également à participer de ne plus
souvent possible à espace autochtone en
direct parce que commenter c'est un
presque un métier que vous avez faire
quand il est question des autochtones
vous aimez bien pouvoir commenter réduit
je me sens commenté mais j'aime ça en
plus expliqué éduqué en même temps à
travers ce qui se passe dans l'actualité
je trouve que c'est un excellent moyen
de rejoindre les gens connaissent
peut-être moins les enjeux les réalités
des premières nations
donc c'est un peu mon dada c'est ma
mission c'est ce que je fais depuis que
je suis toute jeune et je suis très
heureuse de me joindre et d'éclaircies
merci d'être là
alors lançons-nous dans vif du sujet le
gouvernement libéral va t'il à
l'encontre des promesses qu'il avait
fait aux autochtones en expulsant des
deux députés autochtones je vais donner
la parole à madame michèle d'accord
c'est pas grave si on fait un petit
retour en arrière ça a été quand même
vraiment un moment historique qu'on
avait vécu nous en tant que première
nation de lire une bonne personne qui
avait les aptitudes d'occuper ce poste
là et en même temps ça a été la fierté
des premières nations
évidemment un passé important on parle
un boss dans la justice et ce qui est
arrivé dernièrement c'est sûr que ça
nous ont affectés tous qu'on soit
conçoit que n'importe quelle nation ou
au canada
ça nous a tous affectés on a fait
beaucoup de partis pris évidemment par
rapport à ça parce que la fierté vient
d'être tombée ok voilà si ça va à
l'encontre je dirais que oui ça vont à
l'encontre dans le sens que le
gouvernement s'est quand même engagé
justement a engagé une première nation
qui est avec toutes les aptitudes pour
le faire et dans un certain sens où est
ce qu'on peut voir c'est qu'on peut voir
comment nous les premières nations
on a cette intégrité comment nous les
premières nations on est loyal dans tout
ce qu'on entreprend et on peut voir
jusqu'où ça peut aller la loyauté dans
les domaines où est ce qu'on sent bon
c'est ce qui ressort énormément
l'intégrité la loyauté mais je sais pas
isabelle picard est ce que vous êtes
d'accord mais ce qu'on peut pas aller au
delà de la loyauté de l'intégrité faut
aussi avoir de l'intégrité face à son
parti et de la loyauté face à son parti
c'est un peu ce que disait justin
trudeau est lé elle n'a pas été loyal
vis-à-vis moins vis-à-vis mes collègues
la ville partie une question qui est
très complexe
je sais que madame nous rassemble est
rentré est entré en fait en politique
fédérale c'est à une rencontre avec
stephen harper alors qu'à l'époque elle
même était chef régional en coloc
footeux ainsi rendu compte que il n'y
avait rien à faire et que peut-être que
en travaillant de l'intérieur donc en se
faisant élire comme député fédéral
là elle pourrait faire un changement
c'est sur ce changement là qu'elle
voulait faire en fait et ça c'est un peu
il ya une expression d'anglais kim qui
me vient à l'esprit qui dit dans mes
fils d'odin mais fut donc si tu vas en
situant pas en politique active fédéral
tomoe de chance peut-être de changer les
choses alors mais si tu le fais sortir
dans un système politique comme
alignement aussi à quelques bords et
elle se fait beaucoup critiqué pour ça
mais quoi qu'il en soit elle était
conséquence conséquente avec avec sa
prime il savait qu'avec sa démarche de
vouloir changer les choses
c'est une personne qui m'apparaît être
les positionnements autochtones elle est
avocate donc elle et elle est vraiment
très droite
elle a peut-être les défauts de ses
qualités aussi peut-être qu'elle manque
un peu de souplesse mais comme ils
viennent
je pense que l avait un but en entrant
leur et elle a suivi sa pensée première
qui était finalement de faire changer
les choses de faire changer ou même
juste dans ce qu'austin snc lavalin de
faire respecter la loi et elle a eu de
la difficulté à le faire alors peut-être
que pour changer les choses et c'est un
peu rendu compte de ce que c'était aussi
d'être en politique active au
gouvernement fédéral dans le parti
libéral puis peut-être qu'elle était
autre qu il ya plein de couches tout ça
c'est extrêmement complexe je comprends
vous connais pas le dossier jusqu'au
fond sens indiqué ce que vous en pensez
à ce que ça va donc à l'encontre des
promesses que le parti libéral avait
fait là de se tourner vers les
autochtones de commencer une
réconciliation de poursuivre une
réconciliation
techniquement la réponse serait non
techniquement sans garde d'un point de
vue moral par exemple la réponse après
que très différents en ce sens que
depuis 150 ans la façon de faire de la
politique a eu différentes approches au
pays puis celle que toucher beaucoup les
autochtones c'est le caller la
colonisation
justin trudeau a incarné un peu le vent
de changement en fait c'est comme cela
que s'est présentée je pense que surtout
après le vent a repeint les autochtones
voulait y croire mais une approche
différente y est arrivé avec des
intentions de collaboration tco
disent-ils puis à symboliser cet
engagement-là en amant
madame jour des hwasong mais bolt sur le
post mills à la justice d'une femme
procureur puis vous savez la justice le
stand justice qu'est ce qui représente
pour les autochtones c'est quelque chose
que la confiance est paulo c'est des
valeurs différentes donc la m lost est
très calculée à mon avis
puis ça symbolise un engagement donc si
je retourne au tout point de vue moral
je dirais que la réponse est oui alors
madame laborde a demandé pour pouvoir
rester d'ailleurs au sein du parti
libéral avait demandé des conditions
mais des conditions très dures à justin
trudeau est ce qu'il aurait pu répondre
à votre avis à toutes les conditions
quelle année là au cours des derniers
jours les yeux commencent à y répondre à
faire avec monsieur monsieur louis façon
way tournée lorsqu'on apprend depuis
hier ce qui ce qui bloque les gens en
fait c'est que l aurait fait elle-même
d'ingérence selon la perspective on
pense que c'est libéral que couler cette
information je ne pense aussi à fait moi
dans ses 56 ans le céderons pas aux
autres et je trouve ça comme absolument
normal dans sa position dans l'intégrité
cas voulait instaurer dans cette
décision c'est sûr qu'elle voulait pas
que justin trudeau face arrive à ses
fins mais de façon contournée
différentes vers le saas zurich ce
qu'elle avait fait ça serait scellé oui
puis encore là on voit toutes sont
intégrées pei à mon sens à moi alors je
vous pose la question est-ce que à votre
avis le gouvernement libéral va à
l'encontre donc des promesses qu'il
avait faites aux autochtones
c'est à votre tour de répondre de votre
côté aussi envoyé des questions jean
françois van hool est relayée et comme
ça on va pouvoir si vous avez des
questions précises ou des commentaires
les commentaires on va pouvoir les lire
et les questions va pouvoir les poser à
nos invités est ce que tout ce qui se
produit maintenant va avoir un impact
sur cette fameuse réconciliation
je suis certaine dans un certain sens je
lis beaucoup et j'entends beaucoup des
gens
argumenter sur cette situation là autant
il ya plusieurs gens qui disent que
maintenant on veut on voit les voter
pour que les libéraux ne rentre pas ça
c'est des choses qu'on lit un peu
partout bio médias sociaux et en même
temps ça peut être nuisible dans un
certain sens il y avait quand même
réussi le gouvernement trudeau avait
quand même réussi à gagner la confiance
des premières nations en faisant un
geste historique en reconnaissance et
une première nation avec son expertise
et tout a déboulé par la suède où est
bon il ya des enjeux
moi je dois faire plus ce nouveau
quotidien quand même si on connaît
vraiment on aurait dû connaître avant
tôt
qu'est ce qui s'est passé il ya 20 ans
avec ffmc le volet hockey qu'est ce qui
a été fait mais ça ça a été d unir un
héritage des gens qui étaient sur place
à ce moment là et ça ça jamais régler
cette situation là bon ça tombait sur
les mains de dieu dit évidemment qui
voulait trancher et qui a été une
personne à fait loyal je sais pas si moi
aussi j'aurais réagi de cette façon là
parce que je suis très loyal et ne le
fait pas marqué l'année dans des poses
croche je ne peux pas embarquer dans les
poches cross sas abord la loyauté des
premières nations vont jusque là à leur
fournir l'équivalent de leur hangar ce
que le contexte d'avant et qu'est-ce qui
s'est pas fait pour régler cette
situation qui tombe justement à un
moment précis
oui isabelle j'ai envie de répondre
est ce que c'est un flux en fait j'ai
envie de répondre c'est une couche de
plus parce que moi ce soit cet événement
leur si je le prends vraiment en
particulier ou en vase clos
c'est triste de la manière dont ça s'est
passé mais c'est pas tous c'est pas tous
et qui appelait les plaies d'autres
couches en dessous un exemple on va
décortiquer
on est en 2009 1 mais il se trouve et où
on fait plein de promesses
ça y est arrivé en 2016 des joueurs
1015 oui et 2015 aura des élections
alors exactement et donc aux petits
bruits qui viennent exemplaires je
trouve que le citron affaires exemple
l'eau potable
oui et j'ose donc l'eau potable bien vu
il y aurait plus de dos est propre à la
consommation chez les autochtones
très rapidement on exige donc quatre ans
plus tard une petite amélioration mais
on parle d'à peu près 25%
donc on n'y est pas encore il dit moi je
suis pro environnement je suis pro on va
consulter les premières nations avant de
faire exemple un projet sur leur
territoire et l'oeil achète le pipeline
jones monte de toutes ces couches là qui
sont venus mois ma mère m'a bouleversé
il parle beaucoup il s'excuse il ya des
belles promesses il ya des belles
paroles mais les actions et les
résultats surtout il tarde à venir et
ils sont où et moyens tout ce qui est en
dessous de ce qui est en train de se
passer et quand on met tout ça ensemble
là j'ai vraiment un problème on a perdu
la confiance je pense en tant que
première nation
une confiance qui avait peut-être été
donnée trop rapidement à mon avis moi
j'étais encore son égal quand il a été
nommé parce que ça faisait des décennies
des centaines d'années depuis depuis le
début de la confédération con que qu'on
a des relations difficiles avec le
gouvernement fédéral qui tente de nous
assimiler quittant bon de prendre qu'à
toi faut se dire les vraies choses
donc pour moi c'est juste une couche de
plus sinon tout cet océan de sang et or
si c'est maintenant dans le processus
justement de l'investigation avant avant
de prendre position par rapport au
gouvernement très doux justement auprès
des premières nations
c'est comme les formes coloniale sont
encore exercer encore en 2019 on décide
pour nous on croit que c'est bon pour
nous ça qu'on avait demandé ou sans
qu'on nous ait consulté et c'est ça je
pense qu'ils agacent beaucoup this
matter franco-malienne encore existence
aujourd'hui notre droit notre droit de
regard n'est même pas
approché où on n'est même pas consulté
notre droit de d'opinion non plus donc
il ya encore ces formes coloniale qui
sont encore à exercer on parle de
réconciliation mais le mot mois commence
à me déranger parce que ça c'est
vraiment c'est vrai si on regarde les
choses lui au début mais j'ai
l'impression que c'est encore les
premières nations les premiers peuples
qui doivent faire les centraux encore
trop dans cette réconciliation là si on
parlait de décolonisation ou
d'affranchissement loges en barque
mais cette réconciliation là j'ai
l'impression que c'est un boulot qui est
un peu vide de sens j'ajouterai aussi la
réparation avant avant d'avoir une
réconciliation il faut que tu repars ce
qui a été brisé donc il pas encore
tellement d'avancement là dessus son
fils qui t'avait aussi juste mon constat
de cette situation là c'est que on
attend encore des autochtones que nous
nous aident adoption aux façons de faire
cologna leaf on s'entend moment donné
j'avais lu un article qui roméo saganash
avait écrit elle disait qu'elle lui
arrive en politique promener ses valeurs
crie sa façon de procéder crie sa façon
de penser cris j'ai cru à tort que
justin trudeau avait cette ouverture le
cac qui a engagé des gens dans son
cabinet des personnes autochtones sans
réussi ce soit dans son discours est de
toute évidence pour les attendront avec
madame tour de westerbork l'a40 dans les
rangs final oui alors john philpot n'est
plus là jody où il serait bon il n'est
plus là donc chez les libéraux il reste
robert falcon ouellet ont la pendue dans
toute cette histoire là le seul homme
qui reste est le seul où nos colonnes
à votre avis pourquoi on n'a pas entendu
pourquoi il ne s'est pas exprimé sur le
dossier qui concernait évidemment des
gens de sa communauté
je peux pas répondre mais un jeu
surprise je me suis reprise est
généralisée
oui et non oui et non c'est de la
politique tout ça je pense que c'était
mais encore là il est pris entre deux
feux je pense que c'est un peu ça puis
dix huit détenus de toucher à riffles
aussi je veux brûlé il ya tout ce truc
moi je suis certaine dans ma vie qui me
reste à vivre jamais je vais être une
élue du gouvernement parce que tu te
dois d'appliquer justement les règles
les règles coloniale l erreur les règles
du gouvernement même si tu as des
grandes aspirations
même si tu veux vraiment améliorer les
conditions de vie des gens en général
même si tu veux une meilleure qualité
des gens il ya tout un système à
l'intérieur de me demander d'être chef
de ma communauté je veux pas être chef
parce que je suis conscient c'est quoi
être chef parce qu'on est lié avec la
loi sur les indiens qui est encore
désuète oui mais encore elle exerce des
fonds colony et elles sont même pas nos
aspirations et on se doit d'appliquer
d'après les règles déjà établis
oui j'aurais à l'inversé alors quelques
olas porte d'entrée
je pense qu'il doit avoir un gros
mouvement justement de gouvernance
autochtone est ce qu'on peut faire nos
propres règles à nos aspirations pour
les autres mais pas pour les boudent
bourne et non parce qu'on a des grandes
différences dans la vision des choses et
en même temps si on parle de ce côté là
est ce que les gouvernements sont très
justement à donner un accès au
financement parce que si on regarde le
logement on est en pénurie ont l'accès
au logement est vraiment très restreint
l'éducation la santé on a tous sont
gérés n'avait comme des problèmes
sociaux sont particulièrement importants
toutes les communautés sont en mode
survivance économique et donc si on veut
vraiment améliorer les conditions de vie
ça prend évidemment un financement
adéquat parce que toutes les communautés
sont en sous financement sont en mode
survie ce financement là arrivent du
gouvernement fédéral
voilà les bonnes à travers leurs
programmes leurs politiques
c'est ça me vient le disais tout à
l'heure sont pas si on peut penser par
nous sont pensés pour nous il ya une
grosse différence
on croit que c'est bon pour nous ouais
c'est donc peut-être que la réponse est
dans un affranchissement ça dont je
parlais tout à l'heure c'était plus
qu'une décolonisation mais c'est de se
réapproprier en tant que première nation
nous nos manières de faire nos valeurs
notre vision du monde de pas avoir peur
de le faire on est encore veut veut pas
on est tous nés dans un système sous la
loi sur les indiens puis ça fait partie
de notre adn dans le juste de s'en
sortir des fois pour essayer de regarder
les choses de l'extérieur c'est pas
nécessairement évident mais je mens la
solution elle est quelque part il y est
on a autant beaucoup de travail à faire
nous parce qu'on parle de décolonisation
mais on doit aussi éduquer les noms sur
sur l'impact la colonisation sur
l'impact de la loi sur les indiens sur
l'impact de l'héritage des pensions est
rejetée mais on a tellement affaire
d'éducation à réveiller des consciences
que tout le monde il travaille petit peu
peur mais est ce qu'on peut travailler
en masse faire des priorités je pense
que c'est faisable mais il reste à voir
est ce qu on est prêt est ce qu'on est
prêt à travailler notre propre
gouvernance dans une même vision
ça c'est le défi qu'on aura enfin alors
on a reçu une question une question qui
nous vient d' yves cloutier qui
demandent quelle est l expérience
juridique de madame mourir sur le web os
pour être promu ministre de la justice a
fait j'ai eu beaucoup de critiques à cet
égard là les gens et même des médias etc
au québec qui critiquaient son manque
d'expérience j'ai cette année parce que
est avocat depuis 2001 quand même donc
je ne sais pas combien d'années sur le
cv il faut avoir pratiqué pour mériter
puis comme je disais tantôt il y avait
huit à le son talent évidemment elle est
avocate remet à allaiter l'oissu
connaissances autochtones m rapporté à
haut dossier de la justice donc oui ce
qu'aurait que l'expérience d'avoir 4 mai
il y avait autre chose et avaient toutes
sont les deux chiffres qu'elle avait
auprès des autochtones
était chef donc elle est devenue un
député indépendant tu n'avais plus
schwahn tout comme j'ai une firme pote
d'ailleurs qu'est-ce qu'elles vont
pouvoir faire maintenant en tant que
députée indépendante pour faire entendre
leur voix
mais en tout cas au moins à tout le
moins n'auront plus à suivre la ligne
lundi ce qui est quand même intéressant
c'est que dans tout ce que disait tu dit
tout à l'heure il ya aussi stoxx
s'inscrit à l'intérieur donc je pense
qu'ils vont pouvoir être justement
indépendante d'esprit en tout et
éleveurs dans les libres oui je pense
quelque chose de 2,15 intéressant
maintenant est ce que comme
indépendantes elles vont pouvoir avoir
la même influence que comme ils disent
la justice pendant deux ans n'en doute
oui il est là le risque les élections
approchent du gâteau on disait dont
justin trudeau est là depuis ils sont le
parti libéral est au pouvoir depuis
octobre 2015 des élections à l'automne
prochain
est ce qu'elles vont se représenter à
votre avis est-ce qu'elles ont intérêt à
se représenter l'une et l'autre moi je
le souhaite
honnêtement en même temps côté humain je
comprendrais que non c'est un moment
donné la bataille est grosse le coût est
élevé pour m mais oui je souhaite moi
j'aime le leadership de ces dames de
femmes là je trouve qu'elle apporte un
regard différent on a le besoin
donc mon point de vue c'est raul je ne
sais pas je pense que madame louise une
réponse va devoir c'est que madame
philpot ils vont devoir avoir des
réflexions je pense que ça va aller de
soi
intégrer tous à tout ce qui vient de se
passer c'est pas évident et beaucoup en
réaction le son du cor réaction et
maintenant c'est une chose de
l'intérioriser puis deux puis de
réfléchir et de se dire ben est ce que
vraiment les changements que je veux
faire c'est à l'intérieur d'un tel
gouvernement parce que l'on ils y ont
goûté
oui ou est-ce que c'est pas à
l'extérieur justement peut-être en
retournant avec l'iphone avec bon l'apn
bon est ce que est ce que c'est une
manière de faire je suis pas je pense
qu'il va y avoir une grosse réflexion je
suis pas certain non la réponse
d'ailleurs s'était présenté en afn je
crois comme chef national de l'assemblée
des premières nations du canada et ouais
moi je pense que ce serait peut-être une
belle une belle porte pour elle parce
que oui
et là quand même cette force et sait où
est ce que sans bon et en même temps
elle pourrait encore diriger d'autres
belles grandes organisations autochtones
ne serait pas ce que nous maintenant tu
n'es plus dans les règles
gouvernementales dans une grande liberté
d'expression l'autre tu ne t'empêche pas
de dire les vraies choses tu ne
t'empêche pas de revendiquer les les
bonnes choses pour les premières nations
je regarde les commentaires qu'ils
étaient sortis entre autres sur twitter
par rapport justement la chronique que
vous aviez présenté cette semaine cindy
et puis à une personne qui répondait à
gauthier qui dit il n'ya aucun rapport
avec le fait qu'elle soit autochtone ni
le fait qu'elle soit une femme il ne
faut pas tout mélanger donc le fait
qu'elle a été renvoyée et quelqu'un
d'autre qui dit jean-claude du long au
contraire si elle n'avait pas été
autochtone elle aurait été congédié bien
avant car on ne peut garder dans une
équipe intel poignard croyez vous que
c'est le cas ben pour revenir aux
commentaires de madame vauthier je
dirais que l eau potable parce que
dans le fond sabrina voix sauf que comme
je dis ce matin sur tout et on dirait
que tout ce qui est autochtone finit par
rail pour polariser c'est la force des
choses je m'explique mal pourquoi encore
aujourd'hui parce que oui de toute
évidence dans la population sans une
ouverture à comprendre davantage les
réalités autochtones
ah oui enfin la réconciliation qu'on
discute mais en même temps est ce
dossier là était polarisé autochtone
versus non autochtone pareil puis oui
madame ruth elle a raison ça n'a rien à
voir mais c'est une réalité
oui s'il la ministre ou le ministre de
la justice donc n'avait pas été
autochtone à votre avis est-ce qu'on
aurait quand même été aussi sévère à ce
qu'on aurait agi de la même manière en
face parce qu'on sait pas là
le fonds des raisons pourquoi que ces
accords là on dira josé
on a tout un débat autour de deux de
toute cette réalité luxe et dans ces
dames le viol de vie mais en trek on
oublie l'essentiel ce que ce que causer
tout se sait quoi pourquoi ça a été
refusé
c'est quoi le fondement de sa décision
elle doit être légale évidemment mais on
ne s'est pas fait que c'est de cela et
en même temps si on entend si on
retourne un peu avec l'entrevue qui a eu
avec la mini itx au lit ou est ce
qu'elle dit ça a été un bris de
confiance qui a été fait et là il ya une
contradiction avec bris de confiance et
l'aspect loyauté est décrite et là on va
regarder quoi dans quelques mois sous
quel angle ça ne l'est de confiance
voilà un autre commentaire qui étaient
apparues sur la page
espace autochtone justin trudeau a nommé
madame jody web au procureur général
considérant sans doute que cette
nomination
envoyer un message fort aux premières
nations du sérieux de son intention de
mettre la table pour la réconciliation
et a dit mme et madaya elle dit oui
madame moreau mais madame
worsley bond elle n'est une femme n'est
une femme à faire de la figuration en
suivant les directions les directives
n'est pas une femme à oublier le beau
n'est pas une femme à faire de la
figuration en suivant les directives du
cabinet du premier ministre
c'est une femme réfléchi qui a considéré
défendu la dépendance de la justice
ce sur quoi vous êtes toutes les trois
d'accord on comprend très clairement
qu'il ya eu ingérence dans le dossier
est non seulement un partage
d'information et de discussion
et là il ya une jeune fille qui répond
mails à des sous à wall qui dit je suis
totalement en accord
on a entendu parler c'est une jeune
femme qui a déjà une réflexion sur sur
le sujet en forme de personnes
oui une question des stèles pelletier
mesdames philippe attirer bon ne
devrait-elle pas mieux se présenter sous
une autre bannière comme les
conservateurs ou le npd
jamais je ne veux jamais allé chez les
conservateurs j'en suis certaine
certaines au npd je sais pas je sais pas
mais en tout cas pas chez les
conservateurs après la décennie qu'on a
eu très peur ça a été extrêmement
difficile et je verrai bien mal un
autochtone qui quel qu'il soit se
présenter sous la bannière conservateur
peut-être le npd ça se pourrir mon sens
amoindri que ça c'est possible parce
qu'elle va le faire il ya déjà il y
avait quelqu'un de deux du parti qui met
en doute les intentions infectés que
madame christine laborde est en
contradiction ou un peu parce qu est
accusée elle maintenant de d'ingérence
de oui oui oui ce sera remis un petit
peu 2 fraiseurs mais tout est possible
il vient moi si j'étais à sa place
j'aurais de la misère à retourner l'eau
ou et la blessure qui connaissant tout
le système
alain terme le système que les la
population en général ne connaît pas
comme ça que ça fonctionne en interne et
vouloir cacher des choses est ce que je
serai embarquerait dedans mon ciré
si j'étais attiré non je prendrai plus
une plateforme où j'aurai cette liberté
d'expression et où est ce que je
lutterai mieux justement pour enfants
des premières nations revendiquer puis
dire les vraies choses comme il doit il
doit être dit sans avoir de restrictions
moi je la verrais peut-être dans une
autre plateforme aussi importants tels
que la fn écoute moi je dirais les ce
coût représente toi parce que c'est déjà
représentés on a quand même encore
beaucoup de travail à faire parce que
aucune femme encore occupé cette place
là importante et on devrait donner 7
passes un ajustement jody et vous
considérez que l'assemblée des premières
nations a les mains libres peut faire ce
qu'elle veut et à avoir les kits de
justin trudeau facilement henry est
moins loin ce mois ci voulait rien seul
oui j'ai des doutes mais en ayant des
personnages comme madame judy ou un seul
bémol je pense qu'elle peut être que le
vin peut peut être favorable dans ce
sens là parce que c'est une battante
c'est une personne qui a des valeurs
bien a créé des valeurs autochtones
important fait cui patrice après année
cette entité politique l'eau ailleurs qu
est-ce qu à lui j'ai lu ordonné qu'elle
se disait je me souviens plus de
citernes c'était dans sa langue mais
qu'elle disait qu'elle faisait partie de
dans sa culture des femmes fortes qui
n'avait pas pas de remettre à leur place
les chefs qui faisait qu' eric oui je
pense que c'est une femme comme ça et
moi je pense qu'en gouvernance les on
doit avoir plus de femmes et luce c'est
certain on en a pas beaucoup même au
québec qui sont quoi cette ouais enfin
deux chefs sur 43 donc c'est quand même
pas beaucoup
et effectivement le côté féminin
d'emmener des enjeux qui sont portées
par les femmes qui sont autres on n'a
pas eu une place facile à l'intérieur
des modèles de conseil de bande des
modèles qui sont comme tu le disais tout
à l'heure colonialiste parce que c'est
un héritage de la loi sur les indiens
tout ça l'iphone aussi dispensé une
création autres mais quand même
donc j'ai aussi des doutes parce qu'il
ya quand même des limites
maintenant d'avoir une femme leur bon je
trouverais ça extrêmement intéressant
parce qu'à un moment donné si on veut
faire des changements les faits ou sinon
rage chez nous sur le sont les forts
alors il faut il faut redonner
s'inscrire à l'intérieur de de ce qui se
passe de ce que comme comme système de
gouvernance ou alors on fonder d'autres
je sais pas mais il faut le faire je
pense que moi tant qu'à rester sur le
sofa une femme comme ceux des qualités
elle doit passer à l'action elle doit
rester dans le mouvement pour changer
des choses justes alors la seule qu'il a
suivie la seule qui ait finalement s'est
sacrifié pour madame rebosser john
philpot dont qui était président du
conseil du trésor qui était avant
ministre au service aux autochtones
est ce que c'est une bonne décision pour
elle de le faire oui elle voulait
montrer que cette intégrité de madame
personnes répondent était importante et
que c'est ce qui prime est par contre
c'est un sacrifice qu'elle a fait pour
sa propre carrière pour le poste qu'elle
avait aux côtés de justin trudeau
mais quand même elle d'apport l a pas
fait l a pas fait sur un coup de tête
suis certaine qu'elle a dû évaluer sa
situation personnelle premièrement mêmes
que qu'elle reste sous qu'elle pense je
pense pas qu'il y aura de problème à
rebâtir une belle vie quand même
elle est elle autant de capacités aussi
je veux revenir à la question de total à
paris qu'on disait est ce que en tant
qu'organisation autochtones on peut
avoir
on peut amener des changements c'est sûr
qu'on est très limité c'est sûr que
j'aime le fn que ce soit la pnq m me
suis assis à la table des chefs et je
peux voir toutes les frustrations hockey
que le gouvernement nous fait vivre par
rapport aux demandes urgentes de
changement des premières nations et qui
ne sont même pas même pas de données ou
appliquée
ça c'est le gros des filles peu importe
qui peut avoir des grains des grandes
aspirations des grands rêves là on est
confronté à ça on est limité dans ce
genre de pouvoir là j'entends des chefs
qui sont elles vraiment exaspérés par ce
que les côtiers des enfants qui naissent
qu'il ya des surpopulation dans un
endroit fixe est urgent mais on est ils
sont pas entendus de l'autre côté ça
c'est vraiment les gros défi oui ceux
présents justement il ya un commentaire
qui vient de danel natif ailleurs il dit
je suis très fier de ces deux femmes car
elles ont choisi l'intégrité mais l'apn
est une structure qui provient de la loi
sion les indices grise rsa c'est un oui
tout à fait puis en ce sens là on en
sent quand même j'ai jamais été chef
mais quand même j'ai travaillé avec eux
puis à l'intérieur on sent quand même
qu'ils ont parfois les mails il faut pas
se le cacher donc quelle est la solution
je pense que pour l'instant elle n'est
pas sur la table en tout cas c'est ça
c'est ça qui est encore long il ya
l'aspect positif que je vais apporter
c'est aussi quand même qui peut se
renforcer entre ok si on comme une
opposition par rapport à une décision
des gouvernements je me souviens de la
marche ici à montréal des chefs
plusieurs chefs se sont mobilisés et ça
fait quand même des petites des petites
réussites quand même quand on parle
d'éducation ça a été sur l'éducation et
à partir de là il ya eu quand même un
gros boum sur l'éducation
c'est sûr qu'on est liée à des formes
coloniale à des règles coloniale qu on
appliquait qui est la loi sur les
indiens juste l'apn
mais toutes les communautés au québec
sont liés avec un système qui est
vraiment désuète et qui est vraiment qui
réponde vraiment pas à nos aspirations
qui est qu'ils ont un but précis dans
cette loi si vous avez l'intention
d'aller là
c'est vraiment elvis l'extinction de ton
existence d'assimilation et en même
temps je suis tellement conscientiser
mois de l'impact de cette loi alors que
je peux voir que parfois des gens
exercent nous mêmes nous aimons ua sont
exercés forme coloniale mike ladd
je suis étonné et c'est là que je vois
on a tellement de travail à faire
d'éducation sur ce que cette loi est en
train de faire sur nous sur les huit ans
qu'on est en train de faire et qu'on est
en train de retransmettre inconsciemment
il faut éveiller un peuple il faut
réveiller des consciences ça c'est le
gros travail qu'on aura enfin
ensuite si on arrive à réveiller le
groupe de conscience mais voilà où est
ce qu'on s'en vont maintenant et la
problématique des premières nations
c'est vraiment on n'a pas cette force
économique pour couper les fils des
gouvernements bilan des cétacés
maintenant je suis capable de j'ai mon
autonomie financière fait que maintenant
tu ne décides plus pour lui je ne
dépends pas de toi mais on n'a pas
encore cette force économique tant et
aussi longtemps qu'on n'aura pas cette
force économique
envoye tri avec ce système alors il ya
des élections qui approchent dans
quelques mois
qu'attendez-vous des partis qui vont se
présenter on connaît des trois
principaux partis il y en aura peut-être
d'autres mais de ses principaux partis
pour les autochtones
je ne sais plus honnêtement je ne sais
plus on a eu la décennie va un peu on a
eu les promesses trudeau il ya eu la
commission vérité réconciliation qui
avait amené 94 appel à l'action sous
trudeau en a suivi six je pense sur les
94 alors que certaines de ses promesses
je sais plus pour plein de raisons parce
que moralement
peut-être que les futurs chefs vont être
disons en accord avec l'amélioration des
conditions de vie des
la nation tout ça mais le système la loi
la lourdeur la politique le budget
justement le financement qui viendrait
avec conséquemment l'amélioration des
conditions de vie des premières nations
ça me manque beaucoup
au niveau budgétaire c'est le
financement c'est énorme au niveau des
logements au niveau de l'eau potable on
en parlait tout à l'heure la langue la
culture qui sont en péril ce sont les
langues la santé est ce que le système
faire en sorte qu'on peut finalement
répondre à toutes ses promesses là où à
toutes ces bonnes pensées aussi bonnes
intentions la jeu c'est beau je ne sais
pas il est un exercice à être fait à ce
niveau là et la réponse se trouve
peut-être pas justement comme le disait
vianne au niveau du gouvernement fédéral
peut être que ça se trouve dans nos
communautés justement en ayant nous
mêmes une force économique qui va nous
permettre de répondre plus rapidement à
nos propres besoins parce qu'il ya pas
seulement une réalité autochtone y en a
vraiment plusieurs et c'est pas vrai
qu'un programme va répondre à tout tout
les atouts les besoins et à toutes les
demandes des premières nations du canada
au complet
sinon on est à quelques mois des
élections puis je regardais sur le site
du sénat les engagements de du parti
libéral il y en a deux de rencontrer par
rapport aux autochtones donc c'est
décevant puis par rapport à toute cette
histoire là moi c'est vraiment deux fois
parce que comme et belzons ni le vent a
peur on est sorti meurtri comme
autochtone de cet art là on eu l'espoir
avec justin trudeau plat on y comme de
vendre c'est pourquoi donc ces tristes
et viviane pour terminer des comptes
c'est une grande question évidemment je
sais vraiment pas quoi penser parce
qu'on est pris dans un système ça nous
rapporte quoi un nous les premières
nations
c'est toujours ce que je me demande où
on me demande ce qu'est ce que tu va
dépoter
j'ai voulu aller voter quand on s'est
donné le mot pour aller voter pour
débarquer harper est la première
personne que j'ai rencontrée c'était
même un parti libéral
grand sourire qu'il a sur moi je
commence tout mon histoire de
colonisation l'héritage tout ça et c'est
europe et il est parti a perdu son
sourire
pourquoi ni d'abolition mais en même
temps est ce que est ce que ce
gouvernement veut vraiment faire des
choses on parle d'être idiot prix juste
six recommandations
ils sont où les autres qui qui en est
atteint l'objectif pour la réalisation
des recommandations la tva on a des
grosses attentes non on va la commission
vient le provincial ombre mal la
condition des femmes autochtones
disparues assassinées
on a des grandes attentes affirme le
docteur du québec on a soumis des
recommandations 80 une recommandation ok
on a complété les gens consultent et les
femmes
on a consulté le réseau des maisons
d'hébergement on a consulté les familles
et les gens ont des attentes
j'ai l'impression que oui on nous promet
des choses et on nous laisse à notre
faim il ya pas de réalisations qui se
fait si ce nouveau gouvernement veut
vraiment travailler avec nous qui nous
est inclus dans ce processus et ont
feront un plein de matches ensemble pour
la réalisation l on se pense qu'on
aurait une meilleure relation entre
gouvernements mais on n'est pas encore
rendu là parce qu'il ya ce fameux ce
fameux truc de pouvoir c'est moi qui
règne et toi assume alors le dernier mot
je vais le laisser en fait avec un
commentaire c'est daniel n'était fire
qui revient avec ce commentaire ce n'est
pas juste une bataille pour les
autochtones ou pour les femmes mais pour
une politique équitable et surtout on
est vraiment à feu merci beaucoup
d'avoir participé à cette émission je
suis sûr que les émissions les questions
n'avons commencé à arriver mais on doit
se quitter c'est déjà l'heure alors les
questions vont arriver sur facebook si
vous avez envie d'y répondre
allez-y puis continuer à répondre aux
gens merci beaucoup viviane michel
présidente de femmes autochtones du
québec merci beaucoup de maintenance une
présence il avait le picard merci on
devrait se voir la semaine prochaine en
tirer
et puis cindy one merci beaucoup et là
on va vous lire on va continuer à vous
lire dans les pages des espaces
autochtone merci de votre présence merci
à vous d'avoir été là encore une fois
cette semaine
vous pouvez bien sûr continuer à
commenter ce sujet là sur la page du
site ou encore sur facebook sur tout et
partout où nous sommes
et sinon eh bien merci de votre présence
et à la semaine prochaine
[Musique]